The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high-quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation, or to
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
PROFESSOR STRANG: OK, hi.
So I've got homework
nine for you.
Ready to return at the end.
Also, the department asked
me to do evaluations,
but that's the end
of the lecture.
Then, so everybody knows
there's a quiz tomorrow night.
And shall I just remember the
four questions on the quiz?
I mean, not the details but the
general idea of the questions.
Details OK too.
Yes.
Yeah, so there'll be one
question on a Fourier series.
And you should know
the energy equality
for all of these possibilities,
connecting the function squared
with the coefficient squared.
A second one on the
discrete Fourier transform.
Cyclic stuff.
The third one on the
Fourier integral.
And have a look at the
applications to solving an ODE.
I did one in class.
The one in class was
the one in the book
-u''+a^2*u=f(x),
so this will be.
So have a look at
that application.
This is, of course, on
minus infinity to infinity.
and then a fourth
question on convolution.
OK.
And this afternoon,
of course, I'll
be here to answer any
questions from the homework,
from any source,
for these topics.
Are there any questions
just now, though?
I'm OK to take questions.
I thought I'd discussed
today a topic that
involves both Fourier series
and Fourier integrals.
It's a kind of cool
connection and it's
linked to the name
of Claude Shannon who
created information theory, who
was a Bell Labs guy and then
an MIT professor.
So I should put his name in.
Shannon.
OK, so this is, yeah.
You'll see.
So it's not on the
quiz but it gives me
a chance to say something
important, and at the same time
review Fourier series
and Fourier integrals.
So let me start
with the problem.
The problem comes for
an A to D converter.
So what does that mean?
That means, this A is analog.
That means we have a
function, A for analog.
And D for digital.
So we have a function,
like-- So f(x), say,
all the way minus
infinity to infinity,
so we'll be doing,
that's where the Fourier
integral's going to come up.
So that's analog.
All x, it's some curve.
And people build,
and you can buy,
and they're sold in large
quantities, something that
just samples that function.
Say, at the integers.
So now I'll sample
that function and let
me take the period of the
sample to be one, so that I'm
going to take the values f(n).
So now I've got
something digital
that I can work with,
that I can compute with.
And, so the sampling theorem--
Well, I mean, the question is--
Yeah, the sampling theorem
is about this question,
and it seems a crazy question,
when do these numbers --
That's just a
sequence of numbers.
This x was all the way from
minus infinity to infinity.
And similarly, n is numbers
all the way from minus infinity
to infinity, they're
just samples.
When does that tell
me the function?
When can I learn
from those samples,
when do I have total
information about the function?
Now, you'll say impossible.
Right?
So suppose I draw a
function f(x), OK?
And I'm going to sample
it at these points.
All the way, so these are the
numbers, these are my f(n).
Sampling at equal
intervals, because if we
want to use Fourier
ideas, equal spacing
is the right thing to have.
So when could I recover
the function in between?
Well, you'd say, never.
Because how do I know
what that function
could be doing in between.
So let me take the case when
all the samples are zero.
And let's think about that case.
Suppose, what could the
function be if all the samples,
if these are all
zeroes, forever.
OK, well there's one
leading candidate
for the function,
the zero function.
Now, you'll see the whole
point of the sampling theorem
if you think about other,
what other functions?
Familiar functions, yeah.
I mean, we could, obviously,
any, all sorts of things.
But since we're
doing Fourier, we
like to pick on the sines,
cosines, the special functions,
and think about
those in particular.
So, somebody said sines.
Now, what function, so a
sine function certainly,
the sine function hits
zero infinitely often.
What frequency, so sine of what
would give me the same answer?
The same samples.
If I put this sine function
that you're going to tell me,
so you're going to tell
me it's sine of something
will have these
zero values at all
the integers, at zero, one, two,
minus one, minus two, and so
on.
So what would do the job?
Sine of?
Of what will hit zero.
So I'm looking for
a sine function,
I guess I'm looking first
for the function that
just does that.
And what is it? sin(pi*x).
And now tell me some more.
Tell me another function.
Which will also, it
won't be that graph.
sin(2pi*x).
And all the rest, OK?
Let me just use a word
that's kind of a handy word.
Of course, let's put
zero on the list here.
OK.
So this is where k, the
frequency, usually appears.
This is where k--
The word I want to
introduce is alias.
This frequency, pi, is an alias
for this at frequency zero.
Here's the, it's a
different function
but yet the samples
are the same.
So if you're only
looking at the samples
you're getting the
same answer but somehow
the function has
a different name.
So that frequency and this
frequency, and all those others
would be alias.
Can I just write that word
down, because you see it often.
Alias.
That means two frequencies,
like pi and 2pi,
and zero or whatever, that
give you the same samples.
OK, so now comes
Shannon's question.
So we have to make some
assumption on the function.
To knock out those
possibilities.
We want to know a limited
class of functions.
Which don't include these guys.
So that within this
limited class of functions,
this is the only candidate
and we have this possibility
of doing the impossible.
Of determining that
if I know zeroes here,
the function has to
be zero everywhere.
OK, now the question is
what class of functions?
We want to eliminate these
guys, and sort of, your instinct
is, you want to eliminate
functions that, you know,
if it's not zero then it's
got to get up and back
down in every thing.
It could do different things
in different intervals.
But somehow it's got to have
some of these frequencies.
Pi or higher.
Would have to be in there.
So this is the instinct.
That if I limit the frequency
band, so I'm going to say f(x)
is band-limited, can
I introduce that word?
I'll maybe take a
moment just ask you
if you've seen that word before.
How many have seen this
word, band-limited?
Quite a few but not half.
OK.
Band-limited means the band
is a band of frequencies.
So the function's
band-limited when
its transform, this tells me
how much of each frequency
there is.
If this is zero, in some band.
In some band, let's say, all
frequencies below something.
And let's not even
put equal in there.
OK.
But that's not critical.
Band-limited, I have to tell
you the size of the band.
And the size of the band,
the limiting frequency
is this famous
Nyquist frequency,
so Nyquist is a guy's name.
And the Nyquist frequency
in our problem here is pi.
This is the Nyquist frequency.
If we let that frequency,
that's the borderline frequency.
And there would be a similar
Nyquist sampling rate.
So Nyquist is the
guy who studied
the sort of borderline case.
So the point is that if our,
say, band-limited by pi,
I have to tell you, so
band-limited means there's
some limit on the band.
And our interest is when that
limit is the Nyquist frequency.
The one we don't want to allow,
so we-- This is the point.
So this will be the idea.
That if we take this
class of function,
that band-limited-- Those are
called band-limited functions,
and they're band-limited
specifically
by the Nyquist limit.
If we take those,
then the idea is
that then we can reconstruct
from the samples.
Because the only function
that has zero samples in that
class is the zero function.
You see that class
has knocked out,
is not allowing these guys.
Of course, haven't
proved anything yet.
And I haven't shown
how to reconstruct.
Well, of course, we quickly
reconstructed the zero function
out of those zeroes, but now
let me take another obviously
important possible sample.
Suppose I get zero samples
except at that point, where
it's one.
OK, now the question is
what function, f(x)--
Can I fill in, in between zero,
zero, zero, zero, one, zero,
zero, zero, can I fill in
exactly one function that comes
from this class?
So that I have now the answer
for this highly important
sample?
The sample that's all zeroes
except for the delta sample,
you could say.
OK, so I'm looking
for the function now
which is one at that point.
And zero at the others.
So here's a key function.
And I'll show you what it is.
So the function, this function
that I'm going to mention,
will get down here, it'll
oscillate, it'll go forever.
It's not like a spline.
Splines made it to zero
and stayed there, right?
The cubic spline, for example.
OK, but I guess, yeah,
that somehow that function,
we're not in that league.
We're in this
band-limited league.
In a way you could
say that, I mean,
what's the key connection
between dropoff of the Fourier
transform?
So if the Fourier
transform drops off fast,
what does that tell
me about the function?
It's smooth, thanks.
That's exactly the right word.
If the Fourier transform
drops off fast,
the function is smooth.
OK, this is really
an extreme case.
That it's dropped off totally.
You know, it's not just decay
rate, it's just zonk, out.
Beyond this band of frequencies.
And so that gives,
you could say, sort
of a hyper-smooth function.
I mean, so smooth that
you know everything
by knowing the sample.
OK, now I'm ready to write
down the key function,
a famous function that
has those samples.
And that function
is sin(pi*x)/(pi*x).
I don't know if you ever
thought about this function,
and it has a name.
Do you know its name?
Sinc.
It's the sinc function.
Which is a little--
you know, the name's
a little unfortunate.
Mainly because you know,
you're using those same letters
S I N but it's a
c that turns it,
that gives it-- So this is
called the sinc function.
sinc(x).
But the main thing
is its formula.
OK, well everybody sees that
at x=1, the sin(pi) is zero,
at x=2, the sin(pi) is zero, all
these ones we've seen already.
And now what happens
at equals zero?
Do you recognize that this
function, as x goes to zero,
is a perfectly good function?
I mean, it becomes 0/0 at x=0.
But the limit, we
know to be one.
Right?
This sin(theta)/theta is one as
theta approaches zero, right?
So that does have
that correct sample.
And now what's the,
I claim that that
is a band-limited function.
And you'll see that that
function pushes the limit.
It's right-- Nyquist
barely lets it in.
Now here's a calculation.
So this is our practice.
What is f hat of k
for that function?
Now, let me think
how to do this one.
So just to understand
this better,
I want to see that that
is a band-limited function
and what is its
Fourier transform.
OK, now once again here we have
a function where if I want to
do-- How best to do this?
You could say well, just do it.
As I would say on the quiz,
just go ahead and do it.
But you'll see I'm going
to have a problem, I think.
But this gives us a chance
to remember the formula.
So what's the formula for the
Fourier integral transform
of this particular?
So my function is
the sinc function,
sin(pi*x) over sin(pi*x).
So how do I get its, I
do a what here? e^(-ikx),
and am I doing dx or dk?
dx, right?
And I'm going from minus
infinity to infinity.
And am I, do I have a 2pi?
Yes or no?
Who knows, anyway?
Right.
In the book I didn't?
OK.
Now, well, I don't
know the answer.
But so let's, it's much better
to start with the answer,
right, and check
that-- So let me
say what I think the answer is.
I think the answer is,
it's a function that's
exactly as I say, it pushes
the limit from, this is k.
It's the square wave, it's
zero, the height is one.
It's the function that's
zero all the way here,
all the way there.
I think that that's the Fourier
transform of that function.
And just before we check it,
see how is Nyquist got really
pushed up to the wall, right?
Because the frequency
is non-zero right,
all the way through pi.
But pi is just one point there.
And anyway, I think we won't get
into philosophical discussion
about whether, you know,
is that limited to pi?
I don't know whether to put,
you saw me chicken out here.
I didn't know whether to
put less or equal or not,
and I still don't.
But this is making the point
that that's the key frequency.
So this particular
function, what I'm saying
is this particular function
has all the frequencies
in equal amounts over a band,
and nothing outside that band.
And that's the Nyquist band.
OK, now why is this the
correct answer here?
I guess the smart way would
be, this is a good function,
easy function.
So let's take the transform
in the other direction.
Start from here and get to here.
Right?
That would be convincing.
Because we do know that
that pair of formulas
for f connected to f
hat connected to f,
they go together.
So if I can show that I go
from here, that that Fourier
integral takes me
from here to there,
then this guy will take me back.
So let me just do that.
Because that's a very very
important one that you
should be prepared for.
Right.
So now what do I want to do?
Here's my function of k, and
I'm hoping that I recall-- Now,
what do I do when I
want to do the transform
in the opposite direction?
It'll be an e^(+ikx),
right? d what? dk, now.
From k equal minus
infinity to to infinity.
And now I think I do put
in the 2pi, is that right?
And the question is, does that
bring back the sinc function?
If it does, then this was
OK in the other direction.
If the transform's correct
in one direction then
the inverse transform
will be correct.
So I just plan to
do this integral. f
hat of k, of course, is an
easy integral now. f hat of k
is one over, between
minus pi and pi,
so I only have to do over
that range where f hat of k
is just a one.
And now that's an integral
we can certainly do.
So I have 1/(2pi), integrating
e^(ikx) will give me e^(ikx)
over ix.
Now, remember I'm
integrating dk.
Oh, look.
See, we're showing this
x now in the denominator.
That we're hoping for.
And now I have to do that
between k is minus pi and pi.
So this is like,
so I get 1/(2pi),
e^(i*pi*k) minus
e^(-i*pi*x), right?
Over the ix.
OK so far?
I was doing a k integral
and I get an x answer.
And I want to be sure that
this x answer is the x answer I
want, it's the sinc function.
OK, it is.
Right?
I recognize the sine,
e^(i*theta)-e^(-i*theta),
divided by two, I guess.
Is the sine, right?
So I have 1/(2pi).
And here is ix-- Well, no,
the i is part of that sine.
So I'm just using the fact that
e^(i*theta)-e^(-i*theta) is,
this is cosine plus i
sine, subtract cosine.
But subtract minus i sine, so
that will be 2i*sin(theta),
right?
We all know, and now
theta is pi*x here.
So I have two-- let me keep
the i there, and 2i*sin(pi*x).
You see it works.
Just using this, replacing
this by the sine,
the two cancels the two.
The i cancels the i, and I
have sin(pi*x) over pi*x,
that's the sinc function.
OK, so that's the function
we've now checked.
We've checked two things
about this function.
It has the right samples,
zero, zero, zero, zero,
one at x=0 and
then back to zero.
It is band-limited,
so it's the guy,
if this was my sample, if this
was my f(n), zero, zero, zero,
one, zero, zero, zero,
then I've got it.
It's the right function.
OK, we can create
Shannon's sampling formula.
Shannon's sampling formula
gives me the f(x) for any f(n).
Maybe you can spot that, now.
So this is going to use
the shift invariance.
Oh yeah, let's-- Tell me what
the, let's take one step here.
Suppose my f(n)'s were zero,
zero, zero, zero, and a one
there.
So suppose-- This is, for the
exam too, this idea of shifting
is simple and basic.
And it's a great thing
to be able to do.
So this wouldn't be
the right answer.
That function produced
the one at zero.
Tell me what function,
copying this idea,
will produce all zeroes except
for a one at this point.
So I'll put this
question over here.
Suppose I'm all zeroes at that
point but at this point I'm up
and then I go back to zeroes.
What function is giving me that?
You see it does decay because
of the x in the denominator,
it kind of goes to
zero but not very fast.
OK, what's that function?
I replace x by x-1, right.
So the function here
is sin(pi(x-1)),
divided by pi(x-1).
I just change the x to x-1.
Now again, at x=0, this
is sin(pi), sin(-pi),
it's safely zero, but at x=1
that's now the point where
I'm getting 0/0.
And the numbers are right to
give me the exact answer, one.
OK, so now we see what to do
if the sampling turned out
to give us this answer.
And now can you tell
me the whole formula?
Can you tell me
the whole formula,
so now I'm ready for
Shannon's sampling theorem.
Is that f(x), if
f(x) is band-limited,
then I can tell you
what it is at all x.
So I'm going back to the
beginning of this lecture.
It's a miracle that
this is possible.
That we can write down a
formula for f(x) at all x,
only using f(n)'s.
OK, now it's going to be a sum.
From n equal minus
infinity to infinity,
because I'm going to use all
the f(n)'s to produce the f(x).
And now what do I put in there?
So I want my formula
to be correct.
I want my formula to be
correct in this case,
so that if all the f's were
zero except for the middle one,
then I want to put
sin(pi*x)/(pi*x) in there.
The sinc function.
And I also want to
get this one right.
If all the f's are zero, so
there'll only be one term.
If this is the term, I
want that to show up.
OK, what do I-- Yeah,
you can tell me.
Suppose this is hitting at n.
We'll just fix this
and then you'll see it.
Suppose that all the others, n,
n-1, n+1, all those, it's zero,
but at x=n, it's one.
Now what should I have chosen?
What's the correct--
I'm just going
to make it easy for
all of us to, yes.
What's the good sinc function
which peaks at a point n?
Again, I'm just
shifting it over.
So what do I do?
Put in, what do I write here? n.
I shift the whole thing by n.
So that's the right answer
when this hits at n.
So now maybe you
see that this is
going to be the right
answer for all of them.
You see that, we're using
linearity and shift invariance.
The shift invariance is
telling us this answer
for wherever the one hits.
That's what we need.
And then by linearity,
I put together
whatever the f is
at that point, that
would just amplify the sinc.
And then I have to put them
in for all the other values.
That's the Shannon formula.
That's the Shannon formula, and
this function is band-limited,
let's see.
What's the-- Oh, yeah.
What's the, do you
see that this one,
that this guy is band-limited?
We checked, right?
We checked that this
one, sin(pi*x)/(pi*x),
that was band-limited because
we actually found the band.
Now, that just gives us
another chance to think.
Allowed.
What's the Fourier
transform of this guy?
My claim is that it's
also in this band.
Non-zero only in the band, and
zero outside the Nyquist band.
What is the transform of that?
What happens if you
shift a function, what
happens to its transform?
So that's one of the key rules
that makes Fourier so special.
If I took this sine, let
me write this guy again.
This was the un-shifted one.
That connected to
the, what am I going
to call that, the box function.
The box function,
the square wave.
Well, box is good.
Now, what if I
shift the function?
If I shift a
function, what happens
to its Fourier transform?
Anybody remember?
You multiply it by, so
if I shift the function,
I just multiply
this box function,
this is a box function in
the k, times something,
e to the i shift, and
the shift was one, right?
Is it just e to the ik, d
being the shift distance.
Oh, the shift distance was n.
Right.
And possibly minus, who knows.
OK, but what's the point here?
The point is that it's
still zero outside the box.
Inside the box, instead of being
one, it's this complex guy.
But no change.
It's still zero outside the box.
It's still band-limited.
So this is the
transform of this guy.
And then the transform
of this combination
would be still in
the box, multiplied
by some messy expression.
So what was I doing there?
I was just checking that,
sure enough, this guy
is band-limited.
And it's band-limited, it gives
us the right f(n)'s, of course.
Everybody sees that at x=n,
let's just have a look now.
We've got this great formula.
Plug in x=n.
What happens when you plug
in at one of the samples,
you look to see what this A to
D converter produced at time n,
and let's just see.
So at x=n, the
left side is f(n).
Why is the right
side f of that n?
That particular n?
Maybe I should give a
specific letter to that n.
So at that particular sample,
this left side is f(N),
and I hope that the
right side gives me
f at that capital N.
That particular one.
Why does it?
You're all seeing that.
At x equal capital N,
these guys are all zero,
except for one of them.
Except for the one when little
n and capital N are the same.
Then that becomes the one.
And I'm getting f at capital
N. So it will give me that,
for the n=1, the one term, yeah.
I don't know if it was
necessary to say that.
You've got the idea of
the sampling formula.
I could say more
about the sampling,
just to realize that the
technology, communication
theory is always
trying to, like,
to have a greater bandwidth.
You always want a
greater bandwidth.
But if the bandwidth, which
is this, is increased,
well by the way,
what does happen?
Suppose it's band-limited
by pi, oh, by pi/T.
Let's just, I normalize
things to choose samples
every integer.
Zero, one, two, three.
And that turned out that the
Nyquist frequency was pi.
Now, what sampling
rate would correspond
to this band, which
could be-- Well, let
me just say what it is.
That would be the
Nyquist frequency
for sampling every T. Instead
of a sampling interval of one,
if I sample every T, 2T, 3T,
-T, my sampling rate is T,
so if T is small, I'm
sampling much more.
Suppose T is 1/4.
If T is 1/4, then I'm
doing four samplings.
I'm taking four samples,
I'm paying more for this A
to D converter, because it's
taking four samples where
previously it took one.
How do I get paid back?
What's the reward?
The reward is if T is 1/4,
then the Nyquist limit is 4pi.
I can get a broader
band of signals
by sampling them more often.
Let me just say that
again, because that's
the fundamental idea behind it.
If I sample more often, say, so
fast sampling would be small--
Fast samples would be small
t and then a higher Nyquist.
A higher band limit.
More functions allowed.
If I sample more often I'm able
to catch on to more functions.
If I sample-- And
that's what, I mean,
now, communications
want wide bands.
And this is where
they get limited.
I mean, this is, you could
say, the fundamental,
I don't know whether to
say physical limit, sort
of maybe Fourier limit
on sampling theory.
Is exactly this
Nyquist frequency.
OK, questions or
discussion about that.
OK.
So that's an
example that allowed
us to do a lot of things.
I did want to ask for your
help doing these evaluations.
Let me say what I'm going
to do this afternoon.
I'm going to answer all
the questions I can,
and I planned, when
there is a pause,
and nobody else asks, I plan
to compute the Fourier integral
and Fourier series,
say, Fourier series,
for a function that has, it's
going to be like the one today
except this is going to
have a height of 1/h,
and a width of h.
So that's, in case you're not
able to be here this afternoon,
I thought I'd just say in
advance what calculations
I thought I would do.
So there's a particular
function f(x),
it happens to be
an even function.
We'll compute its
Fourier coefficients, in
and we'll let h go to zero.
To see what happens.
It's just a good
example that you
may have seen on older exams.
OK, well can I just
say a personal word
before I pass out--
So evaluations,
if you're willing to help, and
just leave them on the table,
would be much appreciated.
I'll stretch out the homeworks.
I just want to say I've
enjoyed teaching you guys.
Very much.
Thank you all, and-- Thanks.